look this isn't working out okay I mean
I you know it look it's not it's not you
it's me it's me know okay no it's
definitely you it is you look I have
needs all right I I never said that you
and I were exclusive Kohler let's see
you're trying to do something about your
unhealthy relationship with that
temptress yeah that's not the point
Baker okay where have you been with a
ban la yo I mean III judge this year
don't get free III wasn't that last year
it's probably gonna be happening again
this year fingers crossed oh well good
for them so who was the was the judging
event for ah let me tell you
okay so you saw a bunch of games out
there at the there at the Sony judges
day so what's what's the first one we're
going to talk about okay I'm sorry
something to tell you about pixel junkie
okay it's not this summer this is by
kyoto-based QJ Frank I've heard a few
games so this is a PlayStation Network
downloadable games following I mean they
had pixel jump racing and they had pixel
junk monsters and so now this is the
third game in this series and what's
interesting is pixel junk racing was
straightforward slot car racer pixel
junk monsters it was you know a tower
defense type of game this is just unlike
anything that I've ever really played
before wow it's a it's a lot more in
keeping with the sort of really the
minimalist avant-garde games don't you
see on playstation network like flow
like everyday shooter like echo crawl
it's more along those lines I mean it
looks it looks kind of like spore the
cell stage of score like it's a natural
kind of like Europe little organism like
what are you you're called a Grimm ok I
called that because the only things they
can really do our grip and
oh it's portmanteau nice nice and it's a
really beautiful sort of minimalist
environment it was supposed to be a
garden and you're jumping around and
getting from place to place trying to
burst pollen sacs and gather pollen and
pollinate things and then the two things
that you can do are you can you can
shoot the string and you can grab on to
the flowers and spin around yeah you can
you've got a little bit of jumping
ability but you can also shoot out a
little web and loop around and then let
go and let your inner hsieh carry you
any moment to carry you it's a it's a
game about a little jumps and little
arcs and you reach these things called
spectra at the end of the level so it's
incredibly simple gameplay but it's just
very organic you know as it is it's
going along in your pollinating plants
you know new new things are growing that
you can climb on top of and
there's just a beautiful musical score
playing it went to just a hip DJ in
Kyoto and got an hour and a half of
music to go with that all right this
next game I mean what I've heard about
it it's buzz it's their trivia game for
the playstation 3 and honestly I mean
I've heard about this I'm like okay how
many you know pop musicians have buzz if
they already brought out you know is
really bringing something new to the
table or is it just on ps3 now but you
said that it actually has some
interesting new innovations yeah you
know buzz it's basically an interactive
game show it's a game show it's a quiz
game it comes with a controller which
has a huge red button if you bang you
know like a controller in jeopardy you
have the actual you bang the button
right this one comes with four wireless
controllers with this kind of cool well
yeah it's hardly takes a simple
straightforward you know got a parlor
game casual game answering trivia
questions buzzing in whoever buzzes
first answers the multiple choice
questions you've got a host who looks
suspiciously like a muppet but again all
well and good yeah not much difference
from the PlayStation 2 version this
applies to all those other games but the
difference is the difference is it's got
online something they're calling sofa
versus sofa online all right and what
that basically means is everyone in one
location
is on the same team almost as if you're
doing a pub quiz show like you're doing
a family feud or something like that and
so you know up to this point I was like
man you know it's mm-hmm this is fun
game not my type of game you know if you
like this sort of game it's a lot better
than seen it on xbox 360 what really
sets it apart though is it lets players
make their own list of trivia questions
post them online and other players can
review them to score them and rate them
and you don't flag them if they have
offensive comment okay but what it means
is the the five thousand questions they
come with the game are supplemented by
an unlimited number of questions about
you know any topic defense come up with
and I played a special you know gamer
trivia section that i just got literally
pwned yeah so really obscure bit of
knowledge about
salta to nothing about
that's what excites me about it right
right the user-generated content and
that brings us to the third game a
little big planet uh yeah I mean little
big planet obviously the centerpiece of
Sony's user-generated content strategy
going forward yeah and you know i mean i
played this at e3 last year it's amazing
but what they were showing up this time
around the judges day we're a whole
bunch of brand new features that we
haven't checked out yet right absolutely
and for those who don't know yeah
littlebigplanet it's it's a very pretty
very well design two-dimensional side
scroller sort of in the vein of mario
with just adorable little character so
you can customize your parents customize
a facial expressions
and guide them through this
two-dimensional level yeah but what
really sets it apart is that the
controls you're using to move through
the level are also the controls you use
to design your own bottles right and
it's this very very flexible very very
intuitive tool any design levels on the
five basically in this game absolute
designing is the same as playing you can
immediately start testing them out but
they've added for the version that you
actually saw they're going to have any
three are all kinds of other things
right like things that can hurt the
player yeah they're environmental
effects you know a fire and ice level mm
and we got to see we got to see a lot
more about the content creation of
course it the guys at Media Molecule
they are so good that they can you know
not just create objects but sort of
attached behaviors in real time and it's
not like modern country level you don't
have to know how to code you don't have
to know about 3d modeling it really is
as easy as playing the game and it is as
much fun we also got to see a lot more
of the interface what you'll see when
you log into the game
you have the option again playing the
court games that come with it the core
levels which were very fun but then you
have this limitless potential of levels
created by other players which you can
download and rate if you like it or not
wait what other sort of person might
like it it's almost much like YouTube is
it's like a game and of course if
they're down in the promise of getting a
lot of these great superstar designers
they have at Sony you know like imagine
playing Dave Jaffee's a little big
planet level right right right imagine
playing you know a lot of designers
littlebigplanet levels because all they
have to do is buy a copy of the game and
they can make whatever they want and
then upload it absolutely so I mean you
know summing up what you saw you saw a
few other games as well but I mean kind
of summing up everything you saw you
know Sony obviously at this point last
year in a lot of trouble this point this
year I mean the general consensus seems
to be that they're kind of getting the
rack together and they're at least going
to have a good lineup of games this year
is this year you're feeling yeah it's
too soon to say if motor storm is going
to come together no environment looks
great people who thought the old one was
dull like
there was doing two shooters or showing
a new kill zone and the new resistance
they both look promising you know so
much of that comes down to the Polish
that happens at the last minute and then
yeah a lot of sort of interesting quirky
things like this that really have the
potential to
you know bloom once players get their
hands on it and start making their own
content no you know nothing that's gonna
be a knockout punch like Metal Gear
Solid 4 but a lot of games that will
make people really glad they have a ps3
I am jealous i wish i was an e3 judge
someday well no probably no no man
littlebigplanet i got to get me some of
that see maybe if you'd play
littlebigplanet we wouldn't have to be
having this conversation
you